y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por eso no puedo elegir una película
usado de la noche por eso no podía
comprar un regalo por eso mi mamá me
sigue comprando la ropa no me gusta
pasar horas en el local e irme sin haber
elegido nada tengo dos remeras un jean y
estas zapatillas blancas de esa forma no
tengo opción cuando la remera azul está
para lavar uso es tela blanca
no se pusieron a pensar por qué cuesta
tanto porque cuesta tanto elegir yo
realmente admiro a los que no tienen
este problema tiene que haber muchos acá
pero a mí me cuesta siempre me costó
tiene que haber alguien más acá que le
cueste no puede ser el único que no sepa
elegir hasta incluso con cosas más
importantes
cada vez que me preguntaba qué voy a
hacer aquí voy a dedicar decía no hace
falta mucho cuando sea grande pienso
estoy a tres meses de terminar el
secundario y empezar la facultad
entonces yo soy grande bueno tengo que
elegir entonces bueno me puse a pensar
en que soy bueno que me gusta entonces
de los 12 años que entre un colegio
técnico me relaciono en un ambiente de
muchas máquinas muchas matemáticas
muchos cálculos con algunos amigos nos
juntamos a veces a soldar a fabricar
algunas cosas me gusta diseñar los
programas 3d me gusta mucho la
electricidad aprender sobre el circuito
sobre motores vamos a trabajar en el
torno entonces
tengo que ser un técnico o un ingeniero
si el sí
pero bueno pensando un poco yo también
actuó me encanta actuar hago teatro me
encanta subirme al escenario con mis
compañeros y representan distintas obras
distintos personajes construir un
personaje
la primera vez fue la vida es sueño'
yo fui clotaldo
fue una decisión que se me escapó
después
fue en hamlet
yo fui narciso
no sé roches al aire con tu mano así
y con gentileza que la palabra sea
adecuada la acción y de accionar la
palabra esa es la cuestión
después
fue oliver
disculpe un cual castillo de los
canterville soy oliver north oliver
y mañana cita otro personaje esto es y
cuál es la duda yo tengo que ser actor o
no
pero también nuestra tocar el piano
permiso
m
[Música]
[Aplausos]
perdón
con esto caliento un poco
app
es
e
la voz mala nunca en mí
[Música]
bueno cantar no canto
aunque me gustaría también
pero tope del piano con un profesional
también en mi sueño
[Música]
a veces pienso que lindo sería hacer la
música de una película o musicalizar una
película por ahí se tocará algo más
emocionante
y
igual a seis meses pasa que mi abuelo me
pidió que me aprende del himno y hasta
que llegue es perdonar voy a aprender el
resto pero bueno para resumir el tino me
encanta me emociono yo mismo con ser un
tema nuevo
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
es tan lindo
entonces esto que ser pianista
qué pasa también metáfora al tenis
de chiquito que juego siempre siempre me
gustó y daría lo que fuera para que me
salga el revés a una sola mano como el
de federer nunca lo vieron el hace un
momento tan perfecto cuando juega y yo
cada vez que lo hago out siempre es out
y también están los cálculos las
matemáticas y las máquinas
cuántas cosas haces me dicen muchos chef
y cuál de todas estas cosas te va a
dedicar porque todo no puedes hacerlo el
que mucho abarca poco aprieta
qué sé yo
no sé no sé la pregunta que me hago yo
después es porque tengo que elegir entre
una de esas cosas que amo hacer porque
porque una
no
porque porque tomar una decisión tan
difícil una persona de 10 y 7 18 años
tienen que poder tomar una decisión tan
difícil tener que elegir lo que va a ser
durante toda su vida
y si no elijo ahora qué pasa o si elijo
una carrera y después hago otra cosa
nada que ver
hoy si elijo todo
yo no me quiero quedar con una sola
opción que hago yo quiero todas y lo
vengo haciendo bastante bien para que
las voy a dejar
capas todas estas cosas tan diferentes
que parecen ahora se terminan uniendo
algún día no se sabe algo muy bueno
eso lo iré viendo más adelante porque yo
mientras tanto
lo único que pienso hacer es seguir
estudiando para ser el mejor técnico
voy a sirviendo el teatro
perfeccionándome como actor
capas en bici canto
y bueno voy a ahorrar a ver si me puedo
comprar uno como ese
a jugar el viernes al tenis todo los
viernes y los fines de semana y bueno no
me quedará otra que me siga comprando la
ropa gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]